how are you feeling  i believe i owe you  my life  my friend and i are on our way to udea  in search of the ark  father varoot said that we must look for  the morai ruins  we were wondering if  you've ever heard of it  yes  i think so  according to legend  it was the capital of incavia  right up until it sank  i believe the nomads of the salt desert  would know more  their ancestors came from anger  before you set out  get the tome of the pilgrim from brother  allred i'm sure it will prove useful  would you travel to udea and look for a  way to get to morai ruins  what a relief  we could use the crystal jade i heard  abbot lewin regained consciousness  um  [Music]  you can't pass through here if you have  the plague  okay  [Music]  um  [Applause]  you